al final ha llegado tras varios fracasos
y unos cuantos escándalos 2017 cerró con
la primera gran victoria política de
donald trump y el partido republicano
desde las elecciones presidenciales que
llevaron al despacho oval al conocido
magnate de los casinos y la promoción
inmobiliaria
[Música]
hablamos como no de la reforma fiscal
que tras ser aprobada por el congreso
fue firmada por el presidente trump el
pasado 22 de diciembre de 2017
ripoll el tren dels llacs transformar
con félix entre indudable la existencia
de dirección entre tablets ha dicho el
explorer se trata amigos seguro que lo
habéis escuchado de la mayor reforma
fiscal en 30 años y la verdad podemos
decir que tanto su repercusión como la
controversia generada han estado a la
altura de semejante acontecimiento
político
para sus defensores la reforma fiscal
supone una auténtica revolución y muchos
la califican como la mayor rebaja de
impuestos en toda la historia de eeuu
un tipo para sus detractores en cambio
no es más que una pequeña reforma mal
hecha y muy alejada de las promesas que
el presidente hizo durante la campaña
electoral
con streep
andoni fatal
language speicher así que creo que las
preguntas a responder están muy claras
que hay de verdad en todo esto y supone
realmente esta reforma es tan grande
como dicen que podemos esperar de ella
bien veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a ver en este vídeo los aspectos
más positivos y también los menos
positivos de una reforma que como
primera consecuencia podemos decir que
ha conseguido calmar las aguas en el
partido republicano y en cierto modo
reconciliar a donald trump con los
líderes de este partido en las dos
cámaras del congreso y ojo porque tal
como venían sucediéndose las cosas es
algo así como una bonita historia de
reconciliación tras un año de pullas
ataques y recelos fijaos en lo que se
decía en los medios hace apenas unos
meses
pero antes de ver qué podemos esperar lo
mejor y lo peor de esta reforma veamos
que supone realmente una ley que creo
todos tenemos muy claro va a reducir los
impuestos en eeuu pues bien la pregunta
que tenemos que responder en primer
lugar es cuánto reduce los impuestos
realmente es la mayor bajada de
impuestos de la historia
donald trump lo tiene claro atentos hoy
he tenido el honor de firmar la mayor
bajada de impuestos y reforma de la
historia de nuestro país es decir que
según el presidente y también muchos de
los políticos del partido republicano
estamos ante una especie de gran
revolución fiscal una revolución capaz
de ridiculizar las bajadas de impuestos
del mismísimo ronald reagan
grace jones sin embargo amigos antes de
lanzar las campanas al vuelo esperad un
momento porque ya sabéis que donald no
tiene un especial aprecio por la verdad
y sabéis que esta ocasión no es
diferente
[Música]
y habéis escuchado bien esta reforma
fiscal no es ni con mucho la mayor de la
historia de eeuu de hecho no está ni
entre las cinco mayores
y aunque podemos decir que estamos ante
la mayor reforma del sistema tributario
en 30 años porque esta ley amigos cambia
muchas cosas lo cierto es que a la hora
de bajar impuestos bueno no es tan
impresionante
la estimación general es que esta
reforma bajará los impuestos entre el 07
y el 0,9 por ciento del pib durante los
próximos 10 años esto es aproximadamente
15 billones de dólares por cierto un
apunte importante porque es algo que
siempre nos preguntáis en los
comentarios cuando hablamos de millones
aquí en visual político en castellano
siempre nos referimos a la terminología
castellana es decir a lo que equivale a
trillones en inglés
pues bien el caso es que según el comité
para un presupuesto federal responsable
un in tank independiente y no partidista
y también según el propio departamento
del tesoro de estados unidos y estamos
amigos ante la octava mayor reducción de
impuestos desde 1918 tres veces más
pequeña que la de reagan atentos
[Música]
si es posible empezar a pensar que lo
que le pasa a donald trump es que tiene
simplemente alergia a la verdad
pero bien cuáles son los principales
puntos de esta bajada de impuestos
cuáles son sus beneficios vamos allá
[Música]
las luces de la reforma
amigos aunque son muchos los cambios
podemos encontrar dos cuestiones
principales por un lado la bajada del
impuesto sobre la renta es decir el que
afecta a lo que ganan las personas
físicas y por otro los cambios en el
impuesto sobre los beneficios de las
empresas
pues bien en el primer caso en el caso
de las personas físicas podemos decir
que la reducción es muy pero que muy
pequeña para casi todo el mundo atentos
el 80 por ciento de los contribuyentes
verán incrementadas su renta después de
impuestos en menos de un 2%
vamos que muchos ni se van a dar cuenta
y el caso es que en esta cuestión trump
ha incumplido descaradamente su palabra
donald trump prometió un nuevo impuesto
mucho más simple con solo tres o cuatro
tramos y tipos mucho más bajos juego de
corte individual rights from seven
bracket sifón
al final la cosa se ha quedado
prácticamente como estaba con siete
tramos y tipos tan sólo ligeramente más
reducidos que antes y ojo porque eso no
es todo además esta reducción es
temporal si desaparecerá en 2025 salvo
que el congreso cambie lo que aprobó el
pasado diciembre
eso sí una cosa que me gusta de esta ley
es que limita las deducciones por
impuestos estatales y locales es decir
para que nos entendamos castiga a los
estados con impuestos más altos y los
incentiva a bajarlos bien por el otro
lado tenemos la bajada del impuesto
sobre el beneficio de las empresas que
amigos es por así decirlo la joya de la
reforma
[Música]
aquí el impuesto se reduce del 35% al
21% y además cambia el ámbito de
aplicación de este impuesto que deja de
ser mundial para afectar casi
exclusivamente a eeuu me explico esto es
importante hasta ahora cuando las
multinacionales estadounidenses como
google o apple ganaba el dinero en el
extranjero por ejemplo en irlanda a
pesar de haber pagado ya impuestos al
gobierno irlandés tenían que volver a
pagar impuestos en eeuu por lo que
habían ganado en irlanda es decir
pagaban dos veces esto es algo que por
supuesto las empresas no estaban
dispuestas a hacer así que qué pensáis
que ocurría pues que estas empresas
amigos no repatriaban los beneficios a
eeuu los guardaban en centros
financieros como luxemburgo irlanda o
singapur por poner sólo tres ejemplos y
ojo porque las cifras son mareantes
hablamos de más de 2,5 billones de
dólares
pues bien ahora con esta reforma estas
multinacionales prácticamente sólo
pagarán al tesoro de eeuu por los
beneficios que obtengan en este país y
para el dinero que está fuera la nueva
ley contempla que puedan traerlo a casa
en condiciones bastante atractivas al
sonic supply millions of tables overseas
a quien presta a clientes de skype así
que es muy probable que este año
empecemos a ver una gran cantidad de
dinero moviéndose hacia eeuu
[Música]
por cierto un apunte aunque la bajada
sea del 35 al 21 por ciento en realidad
no será tan grande por un lado al mismo
tiempo que baja el tipo del impuesto se
limitan o eliminan algunas deducciones y
decir algunas ventajas que hacían que
las empresas de media pagaran en torno
al 22 por ciento por otro lado aunque el
antiguo impuesto sobre beneficios de
eeuu era el más alto de la ocde si
tenemos en cuenta todos los impuestos
que pagan las empresas no sólo el
impuesto sobre beneficios lo cierto es
que aunque en eeuu pagan muchos pero que
muchos impuestos por lo general en
europa son aún más altos por ejemplo en
españa en francia o incluso en alemania
[Música]
pero aún así aunque no sea tan
impresionante como los republicanos
cuentan sí que va a ser algo bueno para
la economía de eeuu desde ahora el país
será más atractivo para la inversión sus
empresas ganarán más dinero y muchos
beneficios que ahora se retenían en el
extranjero y empezarán a llegar a eeuu
así que por todo esto y por algún que
otro cambio más pequeño por una vez y
sin que sirva como precedente aquí en mi
ser político digo bien por trabajo
[Música]
pero si penséis que aquí termina todo
esperad un momento porque estáis muy
equivocados esta reforma también tiene
puntos negativos
[Música]
las sombras
los que seguís habitualmente este canal
ya sabéis que solemos decir que las
cosas no siempre son tan bonitas como
parecen pues aquí ocurre precisamente
eso por un lado los efectos positivos de
la ley serán muy probablemente mucho más
limitados de lo que el partido
republicano afirma porque me explico
la economía de eeuu está creciendo a
buen ritmo
hay casi pleno empleo y los beneficios
empresariales están en niveles
históricamente altos
es decir ahora mismo las empresas
estadounidenses que ya son muy
competitivas lo que necesitan es sobre
todo menos regulaciones poder comerciar
libremente y poder contratar a los
trabajadores que necesiten entre ellos a
los mejores talentos que puedan traer
del extranjero
como sabéis trump no va en esa dirección
así que si la reforma tendrá efectos
positivos pero no tantos como algunos
piensas
aunque no es el recorte de impuestos más
grandes de la historia es el recorte de
impuestos más grande peor diseñado la
economía está cerca del pleno empleo y
en cambio la deuda nacional está en
niveles récord y creciendo rápidamente
leonard burman cofundador del tax policy
center por otro lado este gobierno
tampoco es que hable mucho de reducir el
gasto público casi que todo lo contrario
quiero aumentar el gasto en
infraestructuras y el gasto militar y
claro con menos impuestos eso significa
más déficit y más deuda pública
y menuda carrera lleva este país
[Música]
y por último amigos la gran olvidada con
esta reforma es la clase media tal cual
como lo escucháis los grandes
beneficiados por esta reforma serán
sobre todo las clases más pudientes por
supuesto entre ellas el propio donald
trump
tenéis peces bien del otro
la madera 3 sep tips
albert with friends man que me permite
enseñar inglés texto we don't wanna be
with you
si le habrá pasado por la cabeza a este
presidente que él y sus empresas serán
muy beneficiadas por esta reforma ahí lo
dejo el partido republicano ha
traicionado a las familias trabajadoras
este engaño fiscal se lleva miles de
millones de la clase media y se los
entrega a los donantes de los
republicanos y a las corporaciones
adineradas con pérez presidente del
comité nacional demócrata
tal vez amigos por todas estas cosas es
por lo que las encuestas dicen que a la
mayoría de los estadounidenses
en principio este cambio no les hace
mucha gracia la percepción general
parece que pasa porque esta reforma se
ha hecho por y para los más ricos de
hecho contra lo que podríamos esperar
muchos líderes del partido demócrata se
están frotando las manos y piensan que
esto es algo que les va a favorecer en
las elecciones de quitar de mandato que
se celebrarán en noviembre el tiempo de
edad pero en fin os doy mi opinión a
pesar de que no es ni mucho menos la
mayor reforma fiscal de la historia de
eeuu ni tampoco la mejor creo que esos
resultados van a ser más positivos que
negativos
eso sí insisto eeuu necesita
más otras medidas que trump ha
descartado y también creo que el
congreso de este país debería empezar a
tomarse mucho más en serio el
terrorífico crecimiento de la deuda
pública y por cierto un último apunte
creo que con esta reforma en cierto modo
ganamos todos' veréis que eeuu reduzca
sus impuestos es algo que limita que
otros gobiernos y ahora estoy pensando
sobre todo en europa tengan la tentación
de subirlos y subirlos de hecho eso es
lo que nos dice la historia
pero ahora turno para ti estás a favor
de esta reforma fiscal déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
como el zinc es excelente
we don't want it with jon